meagan asks you're like a billionaire
right
what do you splurge on Megan I'm not
even sure if I'm a hundred million air
maybe with my assets
you know vaynermedia and Wine Library
are doing well but I splurge on
experiences for example LeBron first
game back in Cleveland against my Knicks
as you noticed today I'm wearing orange
because I'm starting to get ready for
the basketball season you can imagine
why
so experiences you know vacations with
my family and definitely like things
like LeBrons first game back in
Cleveland and they play the Knicks AJ's
a huge Knicks fan more so than even I am
let's go with him to that something me
and my bro can remember when we're much
older it's cool to like sit around if
you're an old man right now and be like
remember one what screams first game
back in Milwaukee with the Lakers that's
like a fun story that those are kind of
things I want to spend money on
experiences paying for my friends to go
on trips when I was younger when they
couldn't afford it I splurged on
spending time with people that I care
about
oh wait subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social